over time we have come to this point  where today's Democrat Party doesn't  stand for any of those things it's  become a party that is of by and for the  elite it has become a party that is  actively trying to undermine our  fundamental freedoms and rights a party  that is hostile towards uh not only Free  Speech but freedom of religion and a  party that has become the war party some  of the criticisms that I saw coming from  Democrat leaders and Talking Heads when  I announced my decision to leave was oh  of course she's going to go join those  anti-war people obviously not referring  to to the Democrat Party so they've just  given up the anti-war apparently when I  was growing up that was is Iraq war and  right code pink the Democrats were  definitely the anti-war party but right  that's not the case anymore it is  clearly not the case